Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Gözde Zülal Solak
Bak heyecanlı değilim dedim,
ama ne yaptım.
Daha gelir gelmez kağıtları düşürdüm.
Gerçekten çok heyecanlıyım,
sahneye çıkmaktan çok farklı bir şey bu.
Hepiniz hoşgeldiniz.
Gerçekten heyecanlıyım,
kimse inanmıyor ama.
(Kahkaha)
Ben heyecanlıyım, bak şimdi gördüm.
Şimdi efendim, hoşgeldiniz dedim mi?
Dedim dedim.
Sosyal medyada kim niye
paylaşmış bilmiyorum ama,
şöyle bir şey var, birçoğunuz
okumuşsunuz bana soruyorsunuz.
Akasya Durağı'nda Sinan
rolünde oynayan Levent Ülgen,
ODTÜ Fizikten 4.00 ortalama
ile mezun olmuştur.
(Kahkaha)
Şimdi efendim, transkriptimi getirdim.
Valla, notlarım sağ olsun.
(Alkış)
Yıl 79, ODTÜ'ye girdim, hazırlık yılları,
peşinden darbe oldu.
(Kahkaha)
Birinci sınıfta zaten
zar zor İngilizce öğrendim.
İğrenç, her gün kavga dövüş.
İlk sömestr 0.83,
ikinci sömestr 1.50.
(Kahkaha)
Çaktık, repeat.
İkinci sene okuyorum birinci sınıfı; 2,25.
İkinci sömestr 2,74.
İkinci sınıfta 2,03 kompleks matematik
yaktı beni orada, complex calculus.
Ondan sonra ne yapmışım,
2,17, üçüncü sınıfa geçtim.
2,47.
2,83.
Son sınıf: 3,07.
Şeref listesi.
(Alkış)
Ve son sömestr: 4,00.
Vallahi belge.
Aldığım dersler ne: Silikon Teknoloji
ve Dünya Tiyatro Tarihi.
Biri seçmeli ders,
ama 4.00'la bitirdim mi?
Bitirdim.
Belgem var mı? Var.
Bazılarının diploması bile yok.
(Alkış)
Benim şükürler olsun,
iki tane kapı gibi diplomam var.
Biri ODTÜ'den, biri Hacettepe'den.
Bu kadar, bu sır aramızda
kalsın, tamam mı?
Herkes 4.00'la bitirdiğimi zannediyor,
ama dört senede bitirdiğimi zannediyor.
Bu aramızda kalsın.
Ama 4.00 var transkriptte,
isteyene gösteririm.
Şimdi efendim, babamın görevi nedeniyle
liseyi Konya'nın Bozkır
kasabasında okudum iki seneyi.
Üçüncü sene Ankara'ya tayin olduk.
Babam bir memurdu,
işte malum ortalık siyasi dönem falan,
babam bir akşam eve geldi.
Bana bir 250 lira verdi
o zamanın parasıyla dedi,
''Dershaneye ilk kaydını yaptırdım.
Taksiti ödedim, bu senin ikinci taksitin.
İstersen bu parayla git
barda pavyonda eğlen,
istersen git dershaneye taksitini yatır,
üniversiteyi kazan,
adam gibi oku,
kendini kurtar, çünkü ben
sana ne bir fabrika verebilirim,
ne bir tezgâh verebilirim, ne bir dükkan,
ne bir tarla, tek yolun okumak,'' dedi.
O gece sabaha kadar ağladım.
Üh, babam niye böyle diyor, diye.
Niye maddi durumumuz iyi değil, diye.
Ertesi gün tabii ki dershaneye yazıldım.
O sırada, dershanede
Kızılay'da gelip gidirken,
tiyatro merakım başladı.
Oyun izlemeye başladım.
İlk seyrettiğim oyun, tabii uzun yıllar
Ankara'dan dışarıda olduğumuz için,
pek tiyatro şansım yoktu, izleme şansım.
İlk izlediğim oyun,
Ankara Sanat Tiyatrosunun
''Sakıncalı Piyade''si, Uğur Mumcu.
Çok etkilendim, çok hoşuma gitti tiyatro.
Başka bir dünyada gibiydim.
Sonra her hafta bir tiyatro izledim,
dershaneye gittiğim her haftasonu
mutlaka bir tiyatro izlemeye başladım.
Sonra sınavlara girdik, şimdiki gibi
iki dakikada hemen sonuçlar gelmiyor,
iki üç ay beklemeniz lazım o zaman.
Sonuçları beklerken bir gün,
Menekşe sokaktan
aşağı doğru yürüyorum arkadaşlarımla.
Ankara Halk Tiyatrosunun
tabelasını gördüm.
Bir an dedim ki, ben tiyatrocu olacağım.
Oyuncu olacağım, dedim.
Arkadaşlarım güldü bayağı.
Ben gittim, kurslar varmış.
Kurslara yazıldım.
Orada bir ay sonra haber geldi,
ODTÜ Fizik'i kazandım, güzel.
Babama birinci aşamayı geçtik yani,
ODTÜ'yü kazandık işte, iyi bir üniversite.
Bu arada, 17. tercihim.
(Kahkaha)
18 tercih yapıyoruz, benimki 17. tercih.
18. tercihim de Dil Tarih Tiyatroydu.
Tiyatro kursları, ODTÜ,
hazırlık çok zor geçtim.
İngilizcem her zaman kötü oldu,
her zaman sorun oldu.
Bu arada parantez, o beş sene
fizik okuduğum boyunca
bir tek soruyu İngilizce okuyup anlamadım.
Hep tahmini; ulan ivmeyi
vermişse, hızı soruyordur.
Hızı vermişse, zamanı soruyordur, diye.
Hani Matematik kolaydı; find the value
dedim mi onu çözüyordum da,
bir tek soruyu anlayarak çözmedim.
Bunu da belirteyim.
Derken hazırlığı zar zor geçtim.
Birinci sene, biraz önce anlattığım gibi,
transkriptte kaldım.
Babam bütün bunları, benim
tiyatroyla ilgilenmeme yordu.
Ki kendisi sanatla ilgilenen bir insandı.
Çok iyi şiir okurdu, hatta yazardı da,
denerdi en azından.
Dedim ki, sen benim tiyatroma karışma,
ben sana bu diplomayı getireceğim.
Söz mü? Söz.
İşte o yüzden bu yükseliş.
Sırf bir an önce tiyatroya
kaçabilmek için.
Harçlığımı hep tiyatro yaparak
Ankara Halk Tiyatrosu
ve Ankara Sanat Tiyatrosundan
kazanarak harçlığımı biriktirdim.
Tiyatro yaptım
ve bu transkripti babama diplomayı
hediye eder etmez,
ilk işim konservatuvara kaçmak oldu.
Tiyatro bölümünü kazandım.
Vallahi orayı da birincilikle bitirdim.
Ama bu sefer şey değil yani,
hakikaten birincilikle bitirdim.
Sonra, Devlet Tiyatroları öyküsü başladı.
Devlet Tiyatrolarına girdim.
Trabzon'a tayin oldum.
O dönemde, tabii tiyatroyu çok seviyorum,
o ilk adım attığım gün,
tiyatroyu ilk izlediğim gün,
yani hani ilk bakışta aşk derler ya,
öyle bir şey oldu.
Yani, bir canavar girdi içime.
Onsuz uyuyamıyorum,
gece rüyalarıma bile tiyatro giriyor.
Trabzon'a gittim, artık bir okul
mezunuyum, tiyatrocuyum
ve Devlet Tiyatrolarında bir elemanım
ve çok büyük bir baskı hissediyorum
üzerimde siyasi görüşlerimden dolayı.
Çünkü Ankara Devlet Tiyatrosunda başlamış,
Ankara Sanat Tiyatrosunda devam etmişim,
ODTÜ mezunuyum, e görüşümün
ne olduğunu söylememe herhalde gerek yok.
Müthiş bir baskı hissediyorum
idare tarafından üzerimde.
Ya da ben öyle sanıyorum.
Ve ben her türlü yanlışlığa,
haksızlığa müdahale ediyorum
ve itiraz ediyorum, tam bir
muhalifim, asi bir insanım.
Bu, idareyi çok kızdırdı.
Bana birsürü cezalar verdiler.
Ve ben, biraz yorulmaya ve yılmaya
başladım, gözüm korkmaya başladı.
Bir gece dedim ki,
bu kadar muhalif olmanın,
bu kadar itiraz etmenin bir anlamı yok,
en iyisi ben idare ile biraz iyi geçineyim
pes edeyim, dedim.
Tam o sırada kütüphanemde
kitaplarımı gördüm.
Nazım'ın kitapları vardı.
Bir tanesini aldım:
Bursa Hapishanesi, okudum.
13 yıl hapis yattın, 13 yıl.
Orada şiirler yazdın, destanlar yazdın.
Oradaki insanlara resim yapmayı öğrettin.
Sen onlardan dokumacılık öğrendin,
13 yıl dayandın.
Ben 13 ay dayanamadım, öyle mi.
Çok ayıp! Çok utandım kendimden.
Dedim ki, ''Mesele esir düşmekte değil,
teslim olmamakta bütün mesele.''
Ve ilk kez orada, bundan sonra
teslim olmamaya karar verdim.
Sonra, Trabzon'daki hayatım devam ederken,
bir gün Melih Cevdet Anday
geldi Trabzon'a.
Yine ben böyle hararetli hararetli
muhalefet yapıyorum idareye.
Bağırıp çağırıyorum.
Melih Cevdet Anday'ın dikkatini çekti.
Size bir şey sorabilir miyim delikanlı,
dedi.
Tabii, dedim.
Siz, dedi, Galileo'yu tanır mısınız, dedi.
Galileo'yu tanımaz mıyım efendim,
ben dedim fizikçiyim,
aynı zamanda Ankara Sanat'da
oyunu oynandı Bertolt Brecht'in yazdığı,
onda da oynadım ben,
ilk kursiyerlik oyunum oydu, dedim.
Peki, dedi.
Giordano Bruno'yu tanır mısınız, dedi.
Tanımaz mıyım, dedim.
Giordano Bruno'nun da oyunu var.
Onu da dedim, okudum.
Çok beğendim, dedim.
Ki anlatacağım öyküyü,
sonra bana Ankara Devlet Tiyatrosunda
Giordano Bruno'yu,
rolünü oynamak nasip oldu.
Dedim, onu da tanırım.
Peki, dedi, sence hangisi haklı?
Hangisini, dedi, kabul ediyorsun?
Tabii ki Giordano Bruno'yu, dedim.
Neden, dedi.
Çünkü, dedim, Galileo pes etmiş,
korkmuş, geri adım atmış,
Dünya'nın, evrenin merkezi
olmadığını söylemiş,
ama engizisyonun
işkence aletlerini görünce
korkmuş geri adım atmış,
bile bile yalan söylemiş.
Tamam evinde gitmiş o hapiste,
yıllarında son eserini yazmış ama,
yine de kendini inkar etmiş.
Ama Giordano öyle mi, dedim.
Yedi yıl engizisyonun
işkencesine direnmiş,
yedi yıl dayanmış, hatta konuşmasın diye
dilini damağına çakmışlar,
damağını yırtmış,
yine ''Tanrı insanın içindedir,
Dünya, evrenin merkezi değildir,'' demiş.
Tabii ki ben bu adamı destekliyorum,
buna inanıyorum.
Kaç yaşındasınız evladım, dedi.
28, dedim.
48 yaşına gel de bir daha konuşalım, dedi.
(Kahkaha)
Allah'a şükür 55 yaşındayım,
hâlâ Giordano Bruno'ya inanıyorum,
hâlâ ona hak veriyorum.
(Alkış)
Elbette Giordano Bruno kadar inatçı,
onun kadar cesur olmam mümkün değil,
ama en azından yüreğimde
hep Giordano Bruno yatıyor.
Ve Ankara Devlet Tiyatrosunda
bu rolü oynadığımda,
bir cumartesi günüydü.
Bu işi seçmemdeki, kararlı olmamdaki,
inat etmemdeki nedeni ve kararlılığı
bir kez daha takdir etmeme sebep olan
bir olay yaşadım.
Gençler vardı.
İçeriden cıvıl cıvıl sesler geliyordu.
Hatta bazı arkadaşlarımız,
ya çoluk çocuk getirmişler,
orta okuldan insanlar getirmişler,
oynamasak mı, ağır bir oyun bu, dedi.
Çünkü işkence görüyor,
en sonunda yakılıyor Giordano,
yakılırken bile dilini parçalıyor.
Dedik ki, olsun ya oynayalım
ve biz oynamaya karar verdik.
Oyun bitti, bir grup öğrenci çıkışa koştu.
Hakikaten böyle giyimlerinden,
kuşamlarından biraz
kenar mahalle çocukları gibiydi,
biraz yoksul gibilerdi.
İşte, benle konuşmak istediler.
Nereden geliyorsunuz, hatırlamıyorum
adını şu okuldan dediler, ama herhalde
yine böyle yoksul semtlerimizden biriydi.
Dedim ya siz orta okul öğrencisi misiniz,
yok dedi, biz lise öğrencisiyiz.
Ha lise bir öğrencisisiniz?
Hayır dedi, lise son.
E yarın dedim üniversite sınavı var,
üniversiteye gireceksiniz.
Evet dediler, öğretmenimiz bize
hani son gün sınavı düşünmeyin,
moral olsun diye getirdi bizi buraya.
Aa ne güzel, dedim.
Oradan bir tane kız çıktı,
Özür dilerim, gerçekten,
burnumun direği sızlıyor.
Ben dedi üniversite okumayı çok istiyorum.
Üniversite okumanın
çok önemli olduğunu biliyorum.
Ama bu oyunu seyrettikten sonra,
mutlaka üniversite okuyacağım, dedi.
Bir kişi kazanmak bile,
bu meslekte benim için bir rekordu.
En büyük başarıydı.
(Alkış)
Heyecanlanacağımı biliyordum da,
ağlayacağımı hiç düşünmemiştim.
Gerçekten tiyatroyla ilgili benim
hayatımda hiçbir zaman bir gelgit olmadı.
En başından beri karar verdim,
en başından beri aşık oldum,
hep sevdim, çünkü ben tiyatroya inandım.
Ben, tiyatronun beni daha doğru
ve daha iyi bir insan yapacağına inandım.
Umarım da öyle yapar.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)